monsieur à brommat merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors msf
qui vient en aide à la france en une des
puissances de ce monde
est ce normal cela c'est normal parce
que pour l'humanitaire il n'y a pas de
géographie particulière d'humanitaire sa
soeur a été des gens qui sont dans le
besoin ou quel que soit l'endroit où ils
se trouvent mais en effet il ya quelque
chose d'étonnant à voir médecin sans
frontière installé un hôpital en france
quand même je ne peux pas contester la
la substance de cette surprise mais il
faut pas surinterpréter la chose la
crise sanitaire l'épidémie de coville a
en effet mis en lumière des carences
hospitalière due à une politique de
restriction une politique d'austérité
qui a engagé depuis maintenant près plus
de 30 ans et dont on voit les résultats
désastreux
aujourd'hui cela étant l'hôpital fann
attentes hôpital que nous mettons en
place
elle elle n'a des fonctions que très
provisoire ce sont le chu et les équipes
médicales de ce chu qui vont à la fois
équipé en matériel cette tante hôpital
et assurer les soins aux malades si le
service de réanimation est débordé car
comme vous le disiez dans votre
présentation
ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le service est encore
capable de faire face à l'afflux de
patients mais on se doute que avec le
pic qui va se profiler dans les jours
qui viennent les services de soins
intensifs vont être beaucoup plus by à
l'épreuve donc c'est dans cette
c'est dans ce contexte là que ce serait
donc d'un côté oui il y a un système de
santé qui craque un système hospitalier
qui est en train de craquer sous les
coups de cette épidémie mais de l'autre
cette tente elle aussi ça veut dire quoi
concrètement cette tante msf dans le chu
d'oran ça veut dire que le système de
santé français n'est pas prêt à
affronter une épidémie aussi mortelles
non du fait que on lui a ôté sa
flexibilité ses capacités d'adaptation
en en faisant une entreprise qui
fonctionne à flux tendu
donc il faut que les services soient
rentables faute de quoi on enferme on
supprime des lits et du coup on
supprimer la capacité d'adaptation d'un
système qui est fait pour pouvoir
répondre à des situations aussi
inattendu et comme par exemple d
épidémie massive et c'est d'autant plus
important que tout le monde le sait
enfin en tout cas tous les gens qui
s'intéressent aux épidémies le savent
nous allons faire face à d'autres
épidémies que ce soit un retour du
corona une deuxième vague qui va
peut-être se produire à l'automne ou au
cours de l'hiver où que ce soit dans
l'avenir des épidémies comme mika
chikungunya le strass c'est parce que
les virus ont dans le contexte actuel de
mondialisation de déplacement rapide de
croissance démographique d'urbanisation
les virus ont une autoroute devant eux
donc il est important de pouvoir se
préparer à accueillir des patients à
répondre aux épidémies y compris par des
soins curatifs et pas seulement par des
soins préventifs et cela ce sont des
capacités qui ont été très largement
diminué voire voire supprimés du fait
des budgets d'austérité qui marque la
politique hospitalière depuis des années
alors on se pose plein de questions on
le voit la france déborder les hôpitaux
saturés manque de moyens matériels
personnel médical sursollicités ailleurs
dans le monde en afrique par exemple que
va-t-il se passer s'ils en font déjà on
a beaucoup de mal à gérer cette crise
sanitaire
la situation est différente en afrique
même si le continent est évidemment
menacée bon pour l'instant on n'est pas
certain mais il ya de bonnes chances
pour que ce soit le cas on n'est pas
certain que le virus résiste à la
chaleur donc peut-être que l'épidémie
sera moins forte du fait du climat
tropical dans la plupart des pays
africains
mais c'est surtout disons la pyramide
des âges le fait que le continent
africain un continent beaucoup plus
jeune et que par conséquent l'immunité
en plus en fonction des germes circulant
l'immunité et peut être
différentes étonné que les personnes
âgées sont tout de même plus
susceptibles de contracter la forme
grave de la maladie dont il ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes mais en face qui est sûr
c'est que l'épidémie va se développer
tout de même en afrique et que les
moyens de traitement pour les malades
aiguë c'est à dire les formes graves de
la maladie sont dans certains pays quasi
inexistant et de toute façon très
largement insuffisant beaucoup plus
insuffisant qu'ils ne sont en europe
donc ce sont principalement les mesures
barrières qu'il va falloir développer et
force est de constater que cela commence
1 grâce notamment à la diffusion des
moyens d'information au fait que par
internet par le téléphone tout le monde
a accès où la plupart des gens oms accès
à la formation sur ce qui se déroule en
ce moment donc la ruée vers les masques
la de l'adoption de mesures de
distanciation sociale tout cela est déjà
en cours en afrique qui on peut
souhaiter que cela contribue à freiner
l'épidémie
mais dans les régions très confiné
malheureusement très confiné je veux
dire dans les régions très surpeuplée
comme par exemple les zones marginales
urbaine les bidonvilles les quartiers
très populaires où il ya une densité de
population très importante
ces mesures barrières sont tout de même
très limité alors très rapidement et
human parce qu'on est en manque de temps
je voulais revenir en france avec le
confinement plus tôt le déconfinement
c'est la question que tous se posent
quand est-ce que ce déconfinement va
arriver en france plusieurs scénarios
envisageables selon vous comment la
france doit-elle procéder à ce
déconfinement voilà ça demanderait un
peu plus de temps et puis je suis pas
sûr d'être la meilleure personne pour
répondre à cela mais je dirais que
puisqu'il va falloir moduler
c'est-à-dire adapter les mesures de
restriction aux situations par exemple
en ville et à la campagne on n'a pas
affaire aux mêmes risques dans des zones
fortement peuplées dans des zones moins
fortement peuplées non plus dans des
zones où il y a eu des foyers et dans
des zones où il n'y en a pas eu
là encore la situation est différente
donc il va falloir moduler ne me ce qui
est certain c'est qu'il va falloir dit
ces usages des tests de manière à
identifier les personnes qui sont déjà
porteuse anticorps et celles qui sont
susceptibles d'être infectés et il va
falloir répondre usage des masques et la
continuité des mesures barrières se dire
il va falloir transformer nos façons
d'être nos modes de comportement social
ce qui n'est pas une mince affaire
ça peut paraître peu de choses mais on
voit dans la pratique que lille une
forte inertie qui lie à une forte
résistance parce qu'ils sont inscrits
profondément dans nos façons de faire et
donc ne plus serrer la main ne plus
faire la bise se tenir à distance faire
la queue dans des dents des super mais
en fin dans là où il ya lieu de faire la
queue tout cela va être assez compliqué
à rentrer à faire adopter de manière
générale mais je pense que c'est ce qui
va nous accompagner pendant des mois et
des mois pas seulement dans la d'ici
l'été
on peut se dire que des mesures de
confinement vont être levés mais
beaucoup plus largement
jusqu'à ce qu'on ait un vaccin et taux
d'immunité collective qui soit élevé ce
qui est loin d'être le cas aujourd'hui
monsieur bon mad merci d'avoir été en
direct avec vous je rappelle que vous
êtes médecin membre et ex président de
médecins sans fontières merci d'avoir
été en direct avec merci à vous